[Music]
Joe first of all it's so great to have
you here in the flesh I mean I would say
that your screen time perhaps quadrupled
tonight how did that feel for you was it
nerve-racking
Knowlton I felt pretty good I was you
know I had a great time it was better
than the first night
well you said so much that you did get
nervous on that first night we now know
that you have done paradise did you feel
more comfortable in paradise I did I did
at first I was nervous but I think it
was normal to be nervous right away but
I think it went pretty well
so fans have completely obsessed over
you what are they going to see of Joe in
Paradise that they didn't get to see
before what are they going to learn
about you and fall more in love with my
personality I mean the fact that I
actually could speak so it's your
personality period yeah yes I think
it'll be I hope they like me but how
does paradise turn out for you gotta
wait and see
are you more successful than you were in
the Bachelorette you gotta wait you see
but you know what I made it past night
one so make out sessions in some
trailers I think there might be a blonde
involved I don't know what you're
talking about
are you single right now mmm gotta wait
and see you can't even see if you're
single or not
are you happy and your romantic life
right now I'm happy where I marry enough
did anything continue for your post
paradise
I still can't answer that there has been
quite a lot of outcry especially for
someone sent home on night one for you
to be the bachelor have actual talks
happened about you maybe being the
bachelor I can't speak of that okay
would you be the best I don't know I
really have you thought about it thanks
Jill one message to the fans I love all
of you
[Music]
[Applause]